Monsieur le Directeur Monsieur le
Rapporteur mes chers collègues nous
poursuivons donc cet après-midi les
auditions de la mission d'information
que notre commission a décidé de
constituer sur la création du fond
Marianne la sélection des projets
subventionnés le contrôle de leur
exécution et les résultats obtenus au
regard des objectifs du faux cette
mission d'information a obtenu du Sénat
de bénéficier des prérogatives des
commissions d'enquête nous entendons
ainsi cet après-midi monsieur Julien
Marion directeur de cabinet de Madame
Sonia bac S secrétaire d'État auprès du
ministre de l'Intérieur et des Outre-mer
chargés de la citoyenneté
nous savons Monsieur le Directeur que
vous êtes arrivé à vos fonctions bien
après le lancement du fond Marianne
alors que son exécution était largement
engagée pour autant votre audition nous
est apparue nécessaire dans la mesure où
nous intéressons tout autant au
démarrage cette opération car son
déroulement et à son contrôle dans le
temps
est également important de savoir quels
éléments d'information vous avez obtenu
à votre arrivée et quelle suite vous
avez souhaité y donner
avant de vous céder la parole pour un
bref propos introductif si vous le
souhaitez je dois vous rappeler
évidemment comme faux témoignage devant
une commission d'enquête est passible de
sanctions pénales
qui peuvent aller selon les
circonstances de 3 à 7 ans
d'emprisonnement et de 45000 à 100000 €
d'amende je vous invite donc à prêter
serment de dire toute la vérité rien que
la vérité levait la main droite et dites
je le jure
merci et je vous laisse donc comme vous
le souhaitez entre 5 et 10 minutes
maximum je ne pense pas atteindre les 5
minutes monsieur le Président je vais
essayer d'être bref pour ce propre
introductif je voudrais vous saluer vous
dire tout le plaisir que j'ai à
m'exprimer devant vous et à répondre à
vos à vos questions
dans ce dans ce bref propos liminaire je
voudrais si vous m'y autorisez partagez
avec vous trois messages qui me semblent
importants et sur lesquels j'aurai je
pense l'occasion de revenir de manière
plus détaillée en réponse à vos
questions la première information que je
souhaite vous livrer donc vous l'avez
rappelé je m'occupe depuis le 13 juillet
2022 les fonctions de directeur de
cabinet madame Sonia bac S qui est
depuis le 4 juillet de la même année
secrétaire d'État chargé de la
citoyenneté auprès du ministre de
l'Intérieur et des Outre-mer la première
information que je voudrais donc
partager avec vous c'est que la première
alerte qui est remontée au cabinet de la
secrétaire d'État au sujet du fond
Marianne date du mois de mars de l'année
2023 je parle bien d'alerte je serai
naturellement si vous le souhaitez en
mesure de détailler les étapes qui ont
conduit à cette alerte
mars 2023 c'est-à-dire très récemment et
je viendrai évidemment de manière là
aussi plus détaillée sur ce qui s'est
suivi ce qui après cette première alerte
la deuxième chose que je souhaiterais
porter à votre connaissance et qui me
semble importante c'est qu'à compter de
cette date donc à compter de la fin du
mois de mars 2023 des qu'une alerte
circonstanciée et remontée au cabinet de
la secrétaire d'État au sujet du fond
Marianne la conduite de la secrétaire
d'État que j'ai mis en oeuvre à sa
demande peut se résumer en deux mots
transparence et réactivité et là encore
ce sera assez facile à démontrer cette
transparence et cette réactivité vous en
avez eu un exemple pas plus tard qu'hier
avec la mise en ligne et la publication
du rapport de l'Inspection générale de
l'administration un concernant la
subvention versée à l'association
usopm publication qui a été suivie comme
vous le savez par la démission du
secrétaire général du cipdr donc
transparence et réactivité je pourrais
là encore l'illustrer
la troisième chose qui me semble
importante de partager avec vous en
guise de propos liminaire c'est que
derrière la gestion du fond Marianne qui
vous
occupe et donc vous aurez à rendre
compte à travers le rapport que vous que
vous publiez derrière les
erreurs les dysfonctionnements les
manquements et sans doute les fautes
nous le savons depuis hier de manière de
manière documentée derrière les
erreurs qui ont entouré la gestion du
fond Marianne il y a une politique
publique c'est la politique de
contrediscaux républicain
cette politique alors je sais que
d'autres des personnes que vous avez
auditionnées ont été amenés à y revenir
de manière détaillée mais je souhaite à
mon tour le faire je ne voudrais pas
qu'on oublie le contexte dans lequel
cette politique publique a vu le jour
son caractère relativement inédit
nouveau
le contexte donc dans lequel elle a vu
le jour qui résulte d'une prise de
conscience collective de la nécessité
d'investir de nouveaux champs
d'intervention pour la puissance
publique et de le faire en particulier
sur les réseaux sociaux puisque c'est là
qu'aujourd'hui semaine le combat qui
s'agit de mener contre des personnes ou
des structures qui s'entraînent de
manière méthodique et déterminée aux
valeurs et aux institutions de la
République
cette politique je souhaite le relire
très fermement devant vous me semble
indispensable elle me semble nécessaire
elle mérite sans doute d'être
affinés mais elle n'en est pas moins
indispensable et je voudrais que cela ne
soit pas oublié voilà ce que je tenais à
vous dire Monsieur le Président Monsieur
le rapporteur mesdames messieurs en
guise de propos liminaire je me tiens
naturellement à votre disposition pour
répondre à vos questions
merci beaucoup monsieur le directeur
pour cette présentation rapide alors je
vais démarrer comme chaque audition pour
quelques questions un peu générales
tout d'abord pour que vous nous parliez
un petit peu de la transition
dans les semaines donc qui ont suivi la
nomination de Madame bacaisse
le cabinet a-t-il eu nouveau cabinet
donc a-t-il eu une réunion en entretien
avec le secrétaire général du cipdr
spécifiquement sur le fond Marianne bien
sûr vous avez eu des contacts mais
est-ce que le fond Marianne a été évoqué
est-ce qu'il a fait l'objet d'un point
particulier dans une relation de de
d'échange sur ou un élucie PDF les
politiques menées etc est-ce que est-ce
que vous avez eu un minima
un document ou une note
des services une espèce de points de
pointe de cette action à ce moment là
je vais essayer de répondre de manière
aussi précise que possible à la question
que vous que vous me posez monsieur le
Président en commençant si vous m'y
autorisez par un rappel un peu un peu
méthodologique c'est-à-dire comment se
passe l'installation d'un nouveau membre
du gouvernement de son cabinet et
comment se passe la transition vous avez
utilisé le mot avec le ou l'amende du
gouvernement qui dans l'équipe
précédente était chargé des mêmes des
mêmes sujets la règle intangible et elle
est immuable elle est rappelée à chaque
remaniement ministériel c'est que quand
un membre du gouvernement quitte ses
fonctions
il est tenu de verser ses archives les
archives de son cabinet à la mission des
Archives nationales du ministère dont il
dépend ce qui a été le cas donc pour
Madame Schiappa quand elle a quitté ses
fonctions de ministre délégués ce qui
veut dire que quand un nouveau membre du
gouvernement est nommé à la suite ou non
d'ailleurs
d'un membre précédent il ne trouve pas
en arrivant les archives du ou des
cabinets précédents ça peut aller
sembler aller soit je tiens quand même à
le préciser parce que c'est une règle
qui rappelait de manière alors vraiment
invariable par le Secrétariat général du
gouvernement à chaque remaniement
ministériel et c'est ce qui s'est passé
quand Sonia baquet ça a été donc nommé
secrétaire d'État la prise des fonctions
le 4 juillet
2022 je voudrais attirer votre attention
sur une petite précision calendaire
entre le départ de Madame Schiappa 16
mai 2022 et la nomination de Madame
baquet dans des fonctions similaires il
s'est écoulé un laps de temps de 6
semaines donc il n'y a pas eu
concomitance entre le départ de Madame
Schiappa et l'arrivée de Madame maquies
pour autant
quant à membre du gouvernement est nommé
dans ses fonctions là encore il y a des
usages qui me semblent des usages assez
sains qui veut que à son arrivée il
reçoit il trouve un dossier qu'on
appelle le dossier ministre dans le
langage courant qui est constitué par
les services sur lesquels ce ministre à
autorité et donc ce dossier en général
assez complet parfois même assez
roboratif
il présente au nouveau membre du
gouvernement les dossiers les équipes
les organigrammes les enjeux les points
d'actualité qui relèvent de son de son
périmètre ministériel j'en viens
maintenant à la réponse plus précise à
votre question quand Sonia baquet est
arrivé au mois de juillet 2022 dans ses
fonctions et moi c'est côté comme
directeur de cabinet quelques jours
après nous avons trouvé un dossier
ministre pour partie composée par la
production du secrétariat général du
cipdr
il n'y avait pas monsieur le Président
dans ce dossier d'éléments particulier
sur le fond Marianne
il n'y avait pas de notes relative au
fond Marianne
dans le dossier ministre qui a été remis
à Sonia baquet et à son cabinet au
moment de leur installation
je vais compléter mon propos puisque
vous avez fait mention des échanges des
entretiens qui ont pu avoir lieu en
complément du dossier ministre et c'est
également comme ça que ça se passe quand
un ministre arrive il rencontre dans les
jours qui suivent son installation les
directeurs d'administration centrale qui
sont placés sous l'autorité et donc très
rapidement à son arrivée Sonia baquet ça
a rencontré le secrétaire général du
cpdr j'ai fait la même chose quelques
jours plus tard lorsque j'ai pris mes
fonctions de directeur de cabinet et
lors de ces échanges que nous avons eu
le fond Marianne n'a pas été mentionné
ni aucune attention aucun signalement
particulier au sujet du fond Marianne il
en va de même pour être tout à fait
précis et complet lorsque j'ai pu
échanger au cours de la deuxième
quinzaine de juillet avec mon entrée
pour faire mon prédécesseur dans les
fonctions de directeur de cabinet que
vous avez auditionné ce matin
donc il n'y a pas eu je le dis de
manière très très claire il n'y a pas eu
ni par écrit ni par des rencontres ni à
l'occasion des échanges oraux qui ont eu
lieu date de signalement particulier et
a fortiori d'alerte sur la question du
fond Marianne
est-ce que
pardon
vous ne vous en êtes pas étonné
inquiéter
c'est une pratique il peut y avoir des
comment dirais des oublis
vu par mois de cette importance
dit autrement et pour compléter s'il
peut me permettre
est-ce que est-ce que vous-même vous
connaissiez le format si vous voulez en
arrivant dans ce ministère et est-ce que
vous-même vous
auriez pu poser la question peut-être en
ayant une connaissance de ce dossier par
comme un citoyen j'allais dire non je
n'avais pas de connaissance du fond
Marianne mais mes fonctions précédentes
ne m'avait pas conduit à en connaître et
donc je vais tout à fait transparent
avec vous je n'avais pas connaissance de
l'existence du fond Marianne au moment
où j'ai pris mes fonctions de auprès de
la secrétaire d'État donc pardon de de
faire ce commentaire
ce qui veut dire que on peut penser
comment la transmission
le fond Marianne n'était pas un sujet
oui ça peut s'expliquer monsieur le
rapporteur par le fait que au moment où
Sonia Baqué c'est son cabinet s'installe
il s'est passé plus d'un an après le
lancement du fond Marianne et entre le
lancement du fond Marianne avril 2021 et
l'installation de Sonia baquet du 22 il
s'est passé plein de choses le
secrétariat général du cipdr en
particulier à poursuivi toute une série
d'actions d'initiatives
l'actualité politique ce
périme assez vite
dit autrement dit autrement
le fond Marianne a connu une impulsion
politique au moment de son lancement en
avril 2021 et ensuite ça a été assez
bien décrit je crois par d'autres
personnes que vous avez auditionner
avant moi ensuite c'est un sujet dont la
mise en oeuvre l'exécution a été
transféré internalisé par les services
de l'administration ce qui est assez
logique il y a rien pour moi d'anormal à
cela et ça peut expliquer donc que
plus d'un an après son lancement il n'y
ait pas eu de d'alerte ou même de
signalement fait à son sujet
oui nous entendons monsieur le monsieur
le Préfet me directeur mais
si personne effectivement à la mémoire
du dossier ni madame bacquez
ni vous-même à la connaissance presque
par une espèce de lecture de
l'information il y a un an avant etc on
peut comprendre que vous pouviez pas de
question là-dessus
mais cela étant dit l'idée si vous
voulez que l'on puisse
mais c'est un constat l'idée que l'on
puisse lancer un grand renfort de
communication une communication sur
une action menée de contre discours
républicains on n'aime pas énormément il
y a pas que ça dans le dans l'histoire
du fond Marianne mais que ça fait quand
même l'objet de de passage nombreux sur
les plateaux de télévision pour évoquer
le sujet par rapport le point qui est le
point qui distingue le fond Marianne de
tout de toute subvention finalement
c'est le rapport entre ce qui s'est
passé en octobre 2020 et la traduction
politique en a été faite et la
traduction politique en a été faite
c'est la traduction de dire on agit nous
on agit et on le dit assez fort même
s'il s'agit en réalité depuis y compris
le rapport de l'ija revient là-dessus ce
n'est jamais qu'un espèce de fléchage de
du fi DP bon voilà rien de plus mais un
label mais sauf que quand on le présente
à la population c'est la création de
fond c'est un sujet majeur c'est des
moyens qui sont donnés etc donc c'est
c'est on entend bien on connaît
l'administration et la façon dont il
voulait on peut communiquer on aurait pu
communiquer en disant juste dans le FDP
r
puisque c'était sa nouvelle appellation
on met un certain nombre on met un peu
plus de moyens à disposition pour des
actions précises ça aurait pu suffire
très largement pour montrer l'action de
l'État non il y a eu un choix et un
choix délibéré d'en faire une opération
spécifique et donc cette opération
spécifique mais on va pas vous
interroger là-dessus puisque vous avez
dit tout ce que vous aviez à dire si je
puis dire donc cette opération
spécifique bon elle
elle se mène avec difficulté
sous l'ancienne ministre et semaines
plus du tout
sauf évidemment au sein du cipdr de
manière assez classique mais rien
d'original et pas de sujets particuliers
là dessus dès l'instant où la nouvelle
ministre arrive et vous-même
très bien
dans dans ce sujet et c'est un point
qu'on a évoqué ce matin avec votre
prédécesseur
il y avait une particularité c'est que
le cpdr pendant très longtemps comme
très souvent dans l'administration une
fois qu'il était en charge
le secrétaire général était en charge
également des appels à projet et de la
sélection des projets c'est à dire que
il y avait bien sûr comme il se doit une
information cabinet un retour cabinet
très bien mais tout ce qui était
cahier des charges
appel à projet relevé directement de
l'administration et le cabinet ne s'en
occupait pas sauf éventuellement pour
faire telle ou telle remarque
complémentaire ajuster etc ce qui peut
ce qui peut s'entendre
il se trouve qu'au moment où votre ou
madame Schiappa
devient ministre et directement à
directement sous ses ordres de le cpdr
c'était la première fois que le
supérieur en tant que tel dépendait
d'une d'une ministre délégué et bien le
cabinet demande à ce que l'information
lui soit remonte non seulement
l'information du soir à remontée c'est
assez naturel mais que par contre la
décision lui revienne autrement dit le
cabinet devient décisionnaire sur les
appels à projets
et pilote l'appel à projet et il doit
effectivement
donner son aval ici
au projet qui sont étudiés par le cpdr
mais finalement la décision finale
revient au cabinet c'est une forme
nouvelle dans cette maison est-ce que
depuis
et peut-être aussi depuis d'ailleurs que
le sujet sur la table est-ce qu'il y a
une interrogation sur ce mode de
fonctionnement
la le mode de fonctionnement que vous
venez de décrire monsieur le Président
c'est poursuivi après
en fonction de Sonia baquet dans des
conditions que je vais détailler dans un
instant est-ce que je voudrais dire pour
commencer c'est que cette répartition
des rôles entre Scarlet de l'autorité
administrative est-ce qu'il y a de
l'autorité politique me semble
ne me semble pas anormal vous avez des
services de l'administration qui
instruisent
qui vérifie la conformité des projets à
la réglementation en vigueur au cahier
des charges vous orientations politiques
fixées qui ensuite
soumettent ces
travaux l'instruction des dossiers à la
validation de l'autorité politique
le FIPD comme vous le savez est une
enveloppe un peu plus de 80 millions
d'euros dont les crédits sont à 80%
déconcentré il reste
une vingtaine de pour cent qui sont
gérés au niveau central et qui sont qui
servent à financer des projets de nature
variables correspondants à des priorités
donc il n'est pas illogique qui est
cette double intervention des services
qui instruisent qui veillent à la
régularité administrative de des
procédures et qui soumettent à la
validation je dis bien à la validation
de l'autorité politique le fruit de
leurs travaux c'est ainsi que moi par
exemple dans mes fonctions actuelles
j'ai pu à 3 ou 4 reprises
réunir des tenir des réunions qui
servaient à valider les propositions
de financement au titre du FIP et sur
l'enveloppe centrale je précise une
chose c'est que
dans l'écrasante majorité des cas il
s'agissait bien d'une validation c'est à
dire qu'on actait la proposition qui
était faite par les services il a pu
arriver dans certains cas que je demande
des compléments d'information parce que
le dossier présenté ne me semblait pas
suffisamment détaillé ou j'avais des
questions sur tel ou tel aspect de leur
contenu il a pu arriver que je demande
de retirer les projets qui me semblaient
pas suffisamment correspondre aux
attentes mais en aucune manière il y a
aucun moment je suis formé là-dessus et
je n'ai le cabinet de la secrétaire
Ethan a injecté si je puis dire des
dossiers nouveaux qui n'est pas été
préalablement instruit par
voilà je rappelle par ailleurs que le
FIPD est une est un fond budgétaire dont
l'enveloppe centrale est
structurellement
soumise à une assez forte tension
budgétaire il y a des interventions qui
parviennent au ministre de l'intérieur
ou à la secrétaire d'État pourtant sur
des demandes de financement au titre
parfois des crédits déconcentrés parfois
des crédits centraux donc il est assez
normal que le cabinet veille à ce que
ces interventions soient prises en
compte pas forcément suivi l'effet mais
enfin prise en compte donc c'est en ce
sens que la répartition des rôles ne me
semble pas choquante et chacun reste
dans son rôle en tout cas nous y
veillons ou bien
vous avez fait une petite incise dans la
limite où vous n'injectez pas vous-même
des projets dans
qui passeraient d'abord par filtre
ministériel avant d'arriver sur
l'administration parce qu'effectivement
si vous l'avez fait c'est pas pour rien
c'est parce que vous avez pu le
constater alors Apple de rapport de
l'IGA et il y a effectivement quelque
chose d'un peu différent dans le fait de
faire venir un dossier via le cabinet
via la ministre le cabinet ou la
ministre ou le cabinet nous verrons
lorsque nous parlerons avec la ministre
concernée mais on comprend bien que dans
ces cas-là lorsque le dossier vient par
le cabinet une espèce de pression morale
on va dire sur l'administration
si le cabinet recommande un dossier
c'est toujours plus compliqué
de le faire donc c'est une pratique vous
n'avez plus que vous motorisez à
préciser mon pro parce que le point que
vous soulevez est important il jouait
pas qu'il y ait de malentendu il peut
arriver que des dossiers ou des demandes
de financement au titre du filet
arrivent directement au cabinet de la
secrétaire d'État par des élus en
particulier et c'est tout à fait naturel
il y a rien de d'anormal à cela mais
dans ce cas là la pratique que nous
menons à la demande de la secrétaire
d'État et et constante nous transmettons
ces dossiers pour examen et pour
instruction service
merci d'être précis sur ce point
alors
le 10 octobre 2022 le préfet Gravel fait
parvenir une note à l'actuelle
secrétaire d'état chargé la citoyenneté
dans lequel laquelle il explique les
raisons pour lesquelles la liste des
lauréats n'a pas été rendue publique
et pour lequel une démarche a été
engagée pour ne pas les mentionner dans
le jaune budgétaire
sur le soutien de l'État il est fait
mention dans cette note d'une demande de
la presse pour obtenir la liste des
lauréats et donc c'est une forme de
réponse
à la presse pouvez-vous nous rappeler le
contexte de laquelle cette note a été
rédigée qui en a été à l'origine si
votre cabinet lui-même
sollicité ou s'il a été sollicité sur
ces sujets là et qu'elles ont été les
suites
à la fin du mois de septembre à une date
que je ne saurais pas vous donner avec
précision mon fourni quelque part dans
les derniers jours de septembre
le conseiller pour la communication de
la secrétaire d'État
porte à ma connaissance
un article de l'hebdomadaire Marianne
sur le fond du même nom
article daté du 30 juin
article dont je n'avais pas eu
connaissance auparavant je note qu'il
était antérieur à l'installation de
Sonia baquet dans ces dans ces fonctions
donc le conseiller pour la pour la
presse et la communication porte à ma
connaissance cet article
donc vous avez que vous avez sans doute
lu et c'est la première fois que
j'entends parler de manière un peu
précise enfin en tout cas un peu
signaler du fond Marianne donc c'est à
la suite de la lecture de cet article
que effectivement je demande au
secrétaire général du cipdr me faire un
point sur le fond Marianne un point un
peu plus détaillé que je n'avais pas eu
jusque là vous l'avez bien noté
et d'où la note à laquelle vous faites
référence note que j'ai donc reçu mais
qui ne contient aucune forme d'alerte
particulière sur le déroulement des
actions ou la mise en œuvre des actions
financées au titre du fond Marianne
pardon
on a parlé du disque moi je vais vous
parler d'une note du 14 octobre 2022 où
Monsieur Gravel toujours
transmet donc au cabinet le détail du
projet du fond Marianne qu'est-ce qui
donc c'est la suite de du document du 10
et
conformément à votre demande et ça
répond cette note répond pleinement
à la commande que vous étiez la vôtre
la première note qui m'est transmise par
Christian Gravel c'est laquelle monsieur
le Président vous avez fait référence ce
born en réalité à une description très
formelle du processus
et ne dit rien du fond
des actions menées ni même des
bénéficiaires
du fond Marianne donc cette note quand
je la lis quand j'en prends connaissance
me semble insuffisante ne répond pas à
mes attentes moi j'ai besoin de savoir
un peu ce qui quels sont les actions et
surtout qu'est-ce qu'on peut penser de
leur mise en oeuvre d'où ma demande
d'éléments complémentaires et là on en
vient monsieur le rapportera à la note
que vous venez d'évoquer
cette note qui arrive dans quelques
jours après sur demande de ma part du
secrétaire général du cipdr rentre un
peu plus dans le détail mais ne fait pas
apparaître d'alerte particulière elle
dresse au contraire un bilan globalement
positif même très positif du déroulement
des actions avec une toute petite nuance
alors vraiment toute petite sur un
projet porté par une association où il
est fait état de l'expression
présidentielle de difficultés sur les
contenus éditoriaux sans que ce soit
l'avantage explicité nous préciser
l'association dont il s'agit sous forme
de ma part de l'association reconstruire
le commun nous aurons je pense
l'occasion de reparler un peu plus tard
je lis la note
cette mention
[Musique]
attire mon attention je demande donc ce
qu'il y a derrière cette mention un peu
un peu sybilline et le scattage général
du CPL me répond qu'effectivement il y a
pu avoir des difficultés sur certains
contenus publiés par une association
bénéficiaire du fond Marianne que ça a
donné lieu à un recadrage de sa part
auprès des dirigeants de l'association
Au mois de je crois juin 2022 se faire
de nata et que ce sujet désormais réglé
qu'il est derrière nous donc je
considère que il n'y a pas matière à
s'inquiéter et donc cette réserve minime
convenance un projet d'une association
cette réserve étant levée je considère
qu'il n'y a pas lieu de s'inquiéter sur
la mise en oeuvre des actions financées
au titre du fond Marianne d'accord donc
c'est en fait un enchaînement très
rapide
un courrier que j'appellerai
son contenu qui ne vous satisfait pas
vous avez un deuxième état des lieux on
vous signale
une petite difficulté qui paraît réglée
donc il n'y a pas de voilà vous n'aviez
pas été alerté avant je dirais les
affaires se poursuivent alors lorsque
Madame
baquet s'est nommée en fait il y avait
déjà eu des difficultés avec une
association puisque le secrétariat jeune
le secrétaire général du cpdr avait
constaté que effectivement des contenus
produits par l'association reconstruire
le commun
visé et traiter de personnalités
politiques voire ce qu'on a déjà vu
n'était il n'y avait pas de lien avec
les objectifs du fond Marianne est-ce
que à ce moment là de ce que j'ai
compris vous n'aviez pas vous de
connaissances particulières d'aucune
sorte sur ces problèmes
je vous le confirme sur le rapporteur
il y a une autre association c'est
le seppm qui a donc reçu la subvention
la plus importante alors qui on va pas
faire l'histoire vous avez dû voir qui
était très élevé sur trois exercices qui
a été réduite de moitié sur le tiers qui
était demandé donc un million 5
675000 ça devient 300 pour finir à 355
il y avait eu des relances
en interne faites depuis le mois de
novembre
2022 est-ce que vous aviez a priori non
été alerté de cette de la situation de
cette association et à partir de quand
avez-vous été alerté comment avez-vous
des vous avez été alerté agis ou réagi
j'indiqué monsieur le rapporteur tout à
l'heure dans mon propos introductif que
les premières alertes d'étaient pour le
cabinet de la secrétaire d'État et la
secrétaire d'État du mois de mars 2023
ce sont les alertes qui concernent
l'uspm
je vais essayer d'être le plus précis
possible
ce qui veut bien dire qu'entre ce que
j'évoquais novembre
2022 les relances
des relances sont faites mais ça n'est
pas porté à la connaissance du cabinet
de la secrétaire d'État il y a une
étanchéité on va dire l'administration
fait son travail et ça pour le coup
vraiment je crois que ça relève du
travail de l'administration que de
s'assurer de la part d'un porteur de
projet qu'il s'acquitte de ses
obligations en transmettant dans les
délais les documents ce genre de
d'informations n'a pas remonté à la
connaissance du cabinet je le pense mars
nous sommes contactés par des
journalistes
avec qui j'avais déjà eu mais je
pourrais revenir si vous le souhaitez à
des échanges dès le mois de décembre
mais pas sur l'US oppm c'est même
journaliste donc ceux qui sont à
l'origine de la première sortie
médiatique sur le fond Marianne donc le
reportage ou 20 heures de France 2 et
l'article concomitant dans les domaines
d'air Marianne le contact à la fin du
mois de mars je reçois la journaliste le
le 22 mars pour être tout à fait précis
les journalistes il y avait les deux
en nous en part de
de la suite de leur travaux parce que ça
faisait en fait des semaines et
peut-être même des mois qui
travaillaient sur le fond Marianne mais
sans nous en rendre compte vous vous en
doutez bien donc ils reviennent nous
voir fin mars le 22 mars précisément
disons voilà sur on a on a trouvé des
éléments sur une association une
association bénéficiaire du Fonds
moyenne qui nous font penser qu'il y a
eu des des irrégularités
qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce que vous en
qu'est-ce que vous en pensez moi je
découvre ces éléments à ce moment là
j'avais été alerté par le secrétaire
général du
cipdr quelques jours avant 5 jours avant
parce que sachant que la journaliste que
je recevais voulait me parler d'une
association je sachant de quelle
association il s'agissait je demande au
secrétaire général du CPA de me faire un
point détailler sur et c'est assez
occasion là le 17 mars dans une autre
qui me transmet le 17
qu'il me fait état de difficultés du
cipdr à obtenir de l'association en
question toutes les pièces
justificatives relatives à la conduite
des actions financées au titre du fond
Marianne
quelques jours après je reçois la
journaliste les journalistes qui sont un
peu plus précis dans leurs propos nous
sommes le 22 mars
48 heures après je voudrais insister
là-dessus moi je rencontre évidemment
immédiatement
à la secrétaire d'État de ces de ces
éléments dans le même temps le 22 23
mars je reçois des mails et maintenant
de la nouvelle gouvernance de
l'association
une personne que je ne connais pas
m'envoie un mail je présentant voilà je
viens de prendre les fonctions de la
Présidence de l'Association uspm je
découvre des choses étonnantes que je
souhaite partager avec vous il m'envoie
une série de document tout ça est
parfaitement convergent avec ce que me
dit la journaliste les journalistes en
même temps donc pour moi il y a quand
même un faisceau de voilà de
une convergence un faisceau d'indices
assez net donc j'en rencontre
immédiatement la secrétaire d'État et
dès le 24 mars donc 48 heures après à sa
demande je préviens l'inspection
générale de l'administration qu'elle va
être saisie d'une mission sur le
versement la subvention à 7 associations
puisqu'à la date du 24 mars nous n'avons
d'alerte que sur 7 associations là
l'uspm
dans le même temps toujours à la demande
de la secrétaire d'État je demande au
secrétaire général du cipdr de saisir la
procureur de la République sur le
fondement de l'artical du code de
procédure pénale c'est deux procédures
ces lignes de l'IGA cesine de la procure
de la République sont initiés dès le 24
mars et formaliser le 29 donc c'est bien
vous qui déclenchez les deux procédures
c'est à la demande de la secrétaire
d'État voilà
j'opère j'opère à sa demande en tant que
directeur de cabinet ce qui est normal
que j'appelle dès le 24 le chef de
service de l'IGA dès le 24 mars et je
demande au secrétaire général du cipdr
de préparer à sa signature à lui une
saisine de la procure de la République
je vais être précise je veux être sûr
que c'est bien l'ordre par l'ordre et
politique absolument et ça correspond à
ce que je vous disais tout à l'heure
monsieur le rapporteur moi dès que je
rencontre à Sonia baquet de la
présomption assez forte de
[Musique]
l'irrégularité à ce stade je ne suis pas
capable de les qualifier davantage sur
le versement d'une subvention à une
association sa réponse est très claire
et l'instruction qu'elle me donnait très
clair transparence réactivité on veut
savoir voilà faut que la lumière soit
faite
très bien donc vous avez répondu par
anticipation un certain nombre de
questions qui allaient venir mais c'est
une c'est une bonne chose et ça permet
d'aller assez vite
juste pour le
une réaction d'abord du directeur
général à votre demande d'article 40
compte tenu de l'historique que vous
avez maintenant c'est à dire d'une
relation qui a été initié
disons de manière un peu particulière on
va dire
initier par une des discussions directes
entre monsieur cifaoui et le cabinet
puis
l'arrivée d'un dossier chez
le secrétaire général donc compte tenu
de ce passé est-ce qu'il y a une
débat un débat c'est pas comme ça que
les choses se disent mais une discussion
dans lequel le secrétaire général
demande peut-être enfin se posent des
questions par rapport à cet article 40
qui est quand même une particularité
si on regarde l'ensemble du schéma le
projet arrive via des rencontres avec le
cabinet précédent pour pas aller plus
loin
un dossier est demandé semble-t-il le
vérifieront auprès du
auprès évidemment
ceci Faou dans la presse dit au début de
me chercher je fais simple mais c'est
tout ça est à valider à vérifier et donc
ça arrive un dossier arrive donc avant
même que le fond Marianne ne soit
annoncé
et dans la vision d'aller sur le fond de
mariage et puis une fois cette
initiative prise au fond vous demandez
au même
de faire un article 40 contre cette
procédure quoi d'une certaine façon je
fais ça est-ce qu'il y a eu une réaction
est-ce que on voudrait dire ce qu'on
pourrait en parler enfin que sais-je ou
non il n'y a pas eu de difficultés
aucunement de la part du secrétaire
général du cpdr et pour être tout à fait
transparent avec vous je me rappelle
assez précisément puis voilà pour le
coup nous parlons de faits qui ne sont
pas très anciens
je me rappelle très précisément que le
secrétaire général m'a dit
découvrir les irrégularités pointés par
voilà et donc il n'y a pas eu de la
moindre difficulté de sa part à
rédiger et signer ce signalement
à la procure de la République c'est
pardon au regard de ce que vous dites je
venais de dire qu'il découvrait je
rappelle que
[Musique]
je dirais les premiers
remontent à novembre de ville 2022 les
relances
vous avez raison sur le rapporteur mais
je crois qu'il faut être très précis les
difficultés
de ses services à obtenir de la part de
l'association les documents les éléments
justificatifs permettant en particulier
le versement de la deuxième tranche de
la subvention rien à ce stade en tout
cas moi je n'ai pas eu connaissance rien
ne laisse apparaître l'effet qui ont été
documentés par le rapport de l'IGA qui a
été mis en ligne sont deux choses
différentes des difficultés à l'évidence
des difficultés à obtenir à rentrer en
contact avec l'association enfin avec
ces dirigeants manifestement et ça déjà
c'est un sujet et des difficultés une
fois le contact établi péniblement des
difficultés à obtenir de l'association
qu'elle envoie les documents les
éléments financiers les éléments de
bilan qui permettent de justifier le
versement de la deuxième tranche de la
subvention oui voilà je mais je pense
qu'il est aussi pour la chronologie la
bonne compréhension de
il était
comment dirais-je indiqué au départ
qu'il y aurait un petit bilan d'étape au
bout de six mois après l'attribution
donc novembre 2022 par rapport à
mai-juin 2021
c'est des mois qu'on a déjà bien étiré
oui de ce point de vue là quand vous
regardez le dossier
comme ça
les choses qui surprennent bon c'est en
gros on a des associations qui
travaillent déjà avec les cipdr qui sont
connus et qui continuent
éventuellement
font un peu plus avec quelques moyens
supplémentaires et puis vous avez en
gros deux associations pour les montants
les plus importants deux associations un
peu nouvelles qui viennent sur ce
principe d'intervenir sur les réseaux
sociaux notamment
et ces deux associations les deux
commentaires sont caractérisés par la
faiblesse de leur fonds propres ou de
leur budget pour l'une 5000 euros
annuels et tout d'un coup 50000 pardon
manuels et tout d'un coup on propose un
projet à 600.000 euros au départ qui se
termine à 335 000 et puis pour la
deuxième une création avec ni l'eau tout
à fait tout à fait récente sur lequel on
porte des moyens de ce point de vue là
quand vous regardez ces dossiers ou vous
en tirez quoi alors évidemment avec
puisque c'est demandé par par un peu par
le règlement c'est d'avoir des
co-financements pour pouvoir dans le
temps poursuivre sans aide
éventuellement donc il faut trouver des
cofinanceurs bien entendu les deux
associés en question n'ont pas trouvé
comment vous qu'est-ce que ça vous
inspire
quand des alertes circonstanciés
remontent autour d'une puis deux
associations sur les 17 qui ont
bénéficié du fond Marianne donc on est
entre fin mars et début avril 2023
ça pose des questions à l'évidence et la
réponse à ces questions elle est assez
simple c'est la saisine de l'inspection
générale de l'administration pour faire
toute la lumière comme la souhaiter la
secrétaire d'État d'abord sur
l'association qui chronologiquement à la
première fait l'objet d'une alerte
l'uspm et ensuite quelques jours après
lorsque des alertes sont remontées des
signalements sont remontés sur une autre
association la réaction de la secrétaire
d'État a été immédiate elle a demandé à
l'Inspection Générale d'administration
d'étendre ses investigations à
l'ensemble
des associations financées au titre du
fond Marianne ce deuxième rapport n'a
pas encore été remis donc prévu pour fin
juin enfin en tout cas c'est
l'information est ainsi un dernier un
dernier point concernant cette
association
dans le rapport
l'inspection générale d'administration
recommande trois points des maîtres un
titre exécutoire
en vue de la restitution de la somme de
127 476 euros
correspondant à des pots de dépenses qui
ne correspondent pas à la convention ou
étant payé après la fin de celle-ci
prendre acte des manquements aux
obligations saturnitaires relevées par
la Mission
compléter la saisine du procureur de la
République quels sont les suites que
vous envisagez de donner à chacune des
trois recommandations du rapport de
l'Inspection générale de
l'administration
le communiqué qui a été mis en ligne
hier sur le site du ministère de
l'Intérieur en accompagnement de la
publication du rapport répond à votre
question les trois recommandations
seront mises en œuvre
ne seront pas mises en oeuvre par les
mêmes autres par les mêmes personnes
cela étant je me dois d'être précis la
première recommandation celle qui
concerne la restitution d'une part
significative de la subvention versée à
l'USPPM ce travail sera effectué par le
service du SGCI PDF donc c'est
ça relève des missions avec un regard
très appuyé je note que l'inspection
générale de l'administration présente
les choses de manière extrêmement
précise détaillée et
d'une certaine manière facilite la mise
en oeuvre de ce titre nous devons
néanmoins les services devront veiller à
la régularité à la solidité juridique
mais incontestablement ce sera mis en
oeuvre la deuxième
recommandation qui
vise à tirer toutes les conséquences des
manquements disciplinaires
observer cette deuxième recommandation
pour le cours relève de l'autorité
administrative
elle concerne en particulier le
secrétaire général du cipdr elle sera
mise en oeuvre lorsque le deuxième
rapport de l'igia aura été rendu pour
des raisons assez évidentes parce que
l'autorité politique qui a commandité
ces deux rapports a besoin d'avoir une
vision globale des choses et une fois
que ce rapport aura été remis il y aura
là encore dans le strict respect des
règles de droit du principe du
contradictoire l'engagement de poursuite
disciplinaire quant à la troisième
recommandation elle relève les agents
publics qui sont à l'origine du constat
de manquement susceptible de recevoir
une qualification pénale c'est-à-dire
les inspecteurs de l'igéa qui ont rédigé
le rapport
merci justement sur la procédure de
contrôle qui pourrait donner lieu à une
demande de remboursement à l'encontre de
l'autre association reconstruire le
commun qui a été initié bon
au début du mois de mai en tout cas de
manière de manière très récente est-ce
que là aussi vous avez participé à cette
décision est-ce que c'est à votre
initiative pour dire pour dire les
choses le cas échéant dans quel sens et
n'est-ce pas finalement un petit peu
tardif par rapport aux réactions et par
rapport aux révélations des enquêtes
récentes
je ne crois pas que ce soit tardif parce
que là encore il faut d'abord le
préalable indispensable à l'engagement
d'une telle action c'est d'établir la
matérialité des faits
on ne réclame pas comme ça
j'allais dire sur un coup de tête la
restitution de somes significatives à
une association dont vous avez vous-même
relevé monsieur le Président qu'elle
avait des moyens assez limités
quand il y a eu la remontée d'alerte
concernant cette deuxième association
donc nous parlons de reconstruire le
commun l'alerte nous arrive dans les
derniers jours de mars ces premiers
jours d'avril elle se concrétise par des
échanges que nous avons avec notamment
des journalistes de Mediapart
là encore un peu de manière parallèle à
ce qui s'était passé quelques jours
avant avec l'US OPM à la demande de la
secrétaire d'État je demande au
secrétaire général du cipdr de me faire
un point détailler et circonstancié sur
en l'occurrence des contenus
à caractère politique pouvant s'éloigner
de l'objet de l'action financée par le
fond Marianne
alors un petit point ça suppose du coup
que les équipes du cipdr visionnent des
dizaines d'heures de production vidéo
dans ce que je veux dire par là c'est
que la note qui finit par nous remonter
quelques dizaines de jours après le
délai de Dijon me semble justifier voilà
et c'est nous recevons effectivement une
note qui est datée du
[Musique]
quelque part autour du 10 avril
j'aimerais vous dire des choses précises
je ne sais pas le 7 avril ou le 10 avril
entre le 7 et le 10 avril une autre je
crois d'ailleurs vous avez été transmise
et qui effectivement sur une dizaine de
pages
retranscrit des propos à caractère
politique mettant en cause des
responsables politiques de divers morts
et moi bah voilà prenons connaissance de
ces de ces éléments je constate qu'il y
a manifestement un écart par rapport à
ce qui était à l'objet de la mission
financée et donc je rencontre à ce
critère des actes qui me demande
évidemment instantanément d'engager et
d'instruire de faire instruire par les
services PDR une procédure de
restitution de partielle de subventions
qui est au demeurant imprévu par la
Convention d'attribution de la
subvention voilà
ça n'a pas ça n'a pas tardé ça n'a pas
traîné et sur cette deuxième association
en particulier monsieur le Président
Monsieur le rapporteur je pense que le
rapport le deuxième rapport de l'igéa
donc nous aurons fin juin dira les
choses et établira les choses de manière
aussi rigoureuse que le précédent
dans une dernière partie je voulais un
peu recueillir votre sentiment sur
quelques appréciations et éventuelles
recommandations que vous pourriez avoir
dans ce type de projet à l'avenir on a
dans le lien qui a été fait avec les
associations et la commande vous avez dû
le en avoir connaissance
un certain nombre de ces associations
ont bien prisé qu'elle ne se considère
pas comme étant des prestataires du du
ou des services du ministère de
l'Intérieur
qu'elle appréciation portez-vous sur ce
cette déclaration voir ce jugement
comment en fait
vous percevez le la limite elle a
relation que doivent entretenir avec le
secrétariat général du cpdr et le
cabinet les associations qui sont
tout de même financer par le FIPD
et qui donc accepte de rentrer dans une
démarche dont elle connaissent le cadre
d'action
je m'associe monsieur le rapporteur à la
réaction des acteurs associatifs que
vous avez je crois auditionné il y a
quelques jours et je crois
qu'effectivement il n'est pas il n'est
pas juste de les considérer comme étant
des prestataires du ministère de
l'intérêt ça me renvoie en réalité à une
considération plus générale sur
ce qu'on a voulu faire à travers le fond
Marianne mais plus globalement à travers
cette politique de de présence
active sur les réseaux sociaux j'ai noté
que l'expression contre discours
républicain
n'avait pas particulièrement vos faveur
mais mais de quoi s'agit-il il s'agit
d'abord de partir d'un constat un
constat qui est qu'aujourd'hui
les personnes qui professent et qui
diffusent des théories hostiles à la
République hostile assez valeurs
à ces valeurs les plus j'allais dire les
plus les plus précieuses à ces
institutions
aujourd'hui ces personnes et ses
institutions leur terrain
ce sont les réseaux sociaux
c'est plus la rue c'est plus les lieux
de culte
le contenu des prêches dans les lieux de
culte c'est beaucoup
assagissent et c'est tant mieux moi je
crois qu'il faut sans réjouir
collectivement aujourd'hui le combat
semaine d'abord sur les réseaux sociaux
et notamment la destination des plus
jeunes de nos concitoyens qui utilisent
massivement ces réseaux sociaux j'ai
trois jeunes enfants j'en fais le
constat tous les jours donc c'est là
qu'il faut être présent et c'est là
qu'il faut être capable de diffuser
un discours mais le diffuser en
utilisant les codes
les les règles du jeu qui sont celles
des réseaux sociaux et je le dis très
lucidement l'administration n'est pas
forcément toujours
suffisamment outillés pour
être
[Musique]
réactiver efficacement présente sur les
réseaux sociaux nous avons besoin de
nous appuyer sur des acteurs qui eux
maîtrisent ces codes qui eux savent
s'adapter interagir de manière efficace
si on le fait avec les les règles
administratives habituelles et alors
encore plus avec la j'allais dire avec
le visage de l'administration c'est à
dire en utilisant des comptes publics on
n'atteint pas nos cibles et donc
pardonnez-moi j'étais un tout petit peu
long sur un plateau mais ce petit détour
pour pourquoi pour pour expliquer que
l'État la puissance publique exprime un
besoin
ce qu'on pourrait appeler dans l'armée
un objectif à atteindre
fais le constat que elle n'est pas
suffisamment outillée pour répondre à ce
besoin et pour atteindre cet objectif
ensuite elle fait le choix et elle
assume ce choix de s'appuyer sur des
opérateurs associés et c'est à eux
ensuite qu'il revient de déterminer
les modalités les voix et moyens les
plus adaptés ça n'est pas
l'administration non mais enfin on est
d'accord néanmoins bon d'abord les
associations on a bien compris ça nous
l'avait dit ça a été dit par votre
prédécesseur ce matin il y avait deux
types de liaisons enfin de convention
possible le gré agréé on a identifié des
acteurs associatifs solides dont on
connaît les pratiques où on
un entretien plutôt annuellement mais
sur le long terme des actions et
un dialogue c'est le grégret et puis
l'appel à projet mais je pense que dans
un cas comme dans l'autre je comprends
bien et je partage aussi le fait que ça
ne soit pas un service extérieur du
ministère parce que voilà mais néanmoins
il y a un cadre d'action ce qui veut
dire est-ce que fort de cette expérience
pour le moins avec des défaillances
c'est pas très heureuse est-ce que vous
imaginez à l'avenir modifier ne
serait-ce que par des conventions qui
seraient qui donnerait le cadre et
poserait un peu les limites tout en
laissant une liberté mais c'est pas il y
a rien de choquant au contraire ça
montre à la fois le la confiance faite à
des acteurs le respect de liberté mais
dans un cadre avec des règles est-ce que
c'est
des évolutions que vous envisagez de
pratiquer à l'avenir très proche si
comme je le pense vous continuez de
vouloir mener ce type d'action
à l'évidence monsieur le rapporteur il y
aura des enseignements à tirer de la
manière dont on sait déployés de ce sont
déployés les actions financières du fond
Marianne nous allons avoir pour ça deux
rapports de l'inspection générale de
l'administration les travaux de votre
propre commission ont certainement nous
éclairer également mais je veux redire
pardonnez-moi si je suis un peu
répétitif que nous nous parlons d'une
politique publique nouvelle qui a été
construite quasiment exilo et dans un
contexte très particulier qui est celui
de l'année 2020 il faut pas l'oublier il
faut essayer de voilà je m'asstrains
essayer de replacer les choses dans leur
contexte à ne pas succomber à une forme
de lucidité a postériori qui est
toujours assez confortable mais qui ne
fait pas avancer beaucoup les choses
donc oui regardons ce qui a pu
dysfonctionner nous allons être aidé par
ça pour ça par différents travaux dont
les vôtres et essayons de poursuivre de
conserver cette politique publique je
redis qu'elle est nécessaire qu'elle est
indispensable en essayant d'être
davantage armés de de garde de fou de
rigueur pour pour l'avenir
j'entends bien je suis comme vous si on
prend la métaphore sportive c'est
toujours facile de refaire le match
et de prendre les avec le recul le
contexte donc moi je mais je veux aussi
souligner que si on se remet dans le
contexte on va dire qu'il y a quand même
un fossé entre les événements qui ont
conduit à la genèse de d'imaginer la
création du fond Marianne qui a donc été
décidé de manière rapide avec des délais
raccourcis pour frapper l'opinion
envoyer des messages voilà aux acteurs
que l'on combat pour montrer qu'il y
avait
détermination sans faille de l'État dans
sa politique et avec le relais des
associations donc
je re situe aussi voilà je veux dire ces
choses-là
dans le on a vu dans l'appel à projet là
aussi pour le moins nous a semblé qui
avait assez peu de rigueur peu de compte
rendu c'est pas finalement il y a six
personnes qui se réunissent mais c'est
plutôt
eu lieu entre l'administration
des membres de démonstration qui passent
dans un cabinet et je le dis comme je le
ressens un entre soi
peu de d'apports de recherche
d'ouverture sur des experts des
connaisseurs avoir un peu une diversité
d'appréciation pas de compte rendu voilà
sur pourquoi on choisit pourquoi on
donne plus pourquoi on donne moins
pourquoi on ne sélectionne pas
vous imaginez là aussi des procédures
peut-être plus juridiquement plus solide
le rapport de l'Inspection générale de
l'administration qui a été rendu public
hier mais en évidence un certain nombre
de
[Musique]
faits de lacunes dans dans le suivi
administratif des choses et je pense
qu'évidemment il va falloir il va
falloir y remédier bien entendu d'accord
et en tout cas l'intention très claire
de la secrétaire d'État d'accord et ce
que vous considérez je vais aussi un peu
insister mais qu'il relève des des
cabinets mystériels de d'être membre de
ce de telles comité de sélection ou de
validation parce que on a les deux mots
sont employés
je vais vous faire la même réponse que
tout à l'heure monsieur le rapporteur
ça ne me choque pas que l'autorité
politique soit menée à connaître et à
valider les propositions qui sont faites
par l'administration sur des dès lors
que ça concerne des politiques publiques
signalées c'est pas la même chose d'être
dans le comité de sélection et ensuite
d'avoir une validation dans le cabinet
que de participer au comité de sélection
ce sont deux étapes un peu différentes
qui ont un peu noyé en réalité dans le
dans le projet et bien parler de
validation monsieur le président
oui j'avais une deux questions une
sur les comment dirais-je les
conventions
d'attribution des subventions notamment
dans le
FIPD est-ce que vous prévoyez
éventuellement de de
d'exclure ça revient un peu à ce que
j'étais mais certaines pratiques ou en
tous les cas vous assurer de la
conformité des actions avec les
objectifs et les attentes du projet on
voit bien là par exemple que certaines
des associations
l'objectif visé par le fond Marianne et
la réalisation des associations il y
avait assez peu de points communs est-ce
que là aussi vous vous attacherez avoir
une forme de rigueur tout en laissant un
espace d'expression voilà pour conjuguer
le cadre et un espace de liberté aux
opérateurs je les appelais comme ça que
vous associatifs notamment que vous
choisiriez
je voudrais monsieur le rapporteur
partagé avec vous le constat que je fais
depuis maintenant près d'un an c'est que
pour ce que j'envoie le travail
d'instruction qui est conduit par les
équipes du cipdr
s'agissant de l'attribution de
subventions au titre du FIPD et mené
avec rigueur
j'ai eu l'occasion de constater ce sont
des fonctionnaires qui sont rigoureux
qui s'attachent à vérifier effectivement
la conformité des actions financières
avec les objectifs poursuivis le respect
des règles formelles il peut y avoir
malheureusement des des exceptions nous
sommes là pour le constater mais je ne
voudrais pas que ça jette du nombre
excessive sur la rigueur donc font
preuve au quotidien les agents du CPL
dans leur mission autour du FIPD
mais je pense que effectivement raison
pour laquelle je l'ai dit ce matin on
est ici au Parlement n'est pas un
tribunal on essaie d'avoir d'établir la
matérialité des faits la chronologie les
peut-être les mauvaises décisions les
pratiques trop souples le manque de
contrôle
pour ce qui me concerne je voulais
savoir dans les associations on voit
quand même que certaines associations
avaient des budgets familiques et se
trouver d'un coup propulsé
dans des domaines n'avaient pas à
connaître a priori dans ce dans ce cas
de figure avec des budgets très
importants
voire même pour une et le laisser et là
aussi un budget important nous avons
l'occasion de le dire en règle générale
c'est ce que disait récemment notre
collègue le sénateur est blé
les associations quand elles obtiennent
des pour obtenir des chiens de
collectivités locales souvent il faut de
l'antériorité au moins un autre exercice
un budget un conseil administration là
quasiment ex ni l'eau ou avec des
budgets faibles et sans rapport avec
l'objet de l'appel à projet est-ce que
vous
[Musique]
envisagez en tous les cas de je dirais
de tenir compte peut-être de d'un
historique de règles d'antériorité qui
serait posée qui permettrait d'avoir des
garanties
vous allez me dire peut-être et c'est ce
qui a été fait avec certaines d'entre
elles
dans ce cas là elle rentre dans le Grey
agréé mais moi je dirais pas forcément
parce que quand on met en place un label
sur une action nouvelle supplémentaire
qu'on veut plus voyante on peut aussi
s'appuyer sur des associations déjà
solides mais qui mettent
des moyens supplémentaires parce
qu'elles ont un avantage peut-être c'est
d'avoir de l'antériorité le savoir et
elles seront identifiées le mode
opératoire
les règles que vous venez de rappeler
monsieur le rapporteur il existe
et les critères qui doivent normalement
le tamis qui doit être appliqué à
l'appui de l'examen de me demande de
subvention le contrôle de la publication
des comptes des instances dirigeantes
des atouts tout ça existe ici il s'agit
de le mettre en oeuvre donc là vous
dites
il y a eu il y a une défaillance je
constate à la lecture du rapport de
l'Inspection générale de
l'administration que sur l'uspm en tout
cas
nous verrons ce que le deuxième rapport
de l'igéa mais sur l'US oppm elle est
évident s'il y a eu peut-être une
insuffisant contrôle de la du respect de
ces critères
une des questions qu'on peut se poser
d'ailleurs moi je suis toujours un peu
étonné
que des projets d'Emma alors que le
budget n'est pas bouclé c'est à dire une
association capable de budget on fait un
projet significatif ce projet
significatif comprendre 35 % de
financement autre que celui du FIPD et
on démarre malgré tout à l'aveugle et on
démarre on donne la première subvention
qui est quand même très significative
sans être sûr même pas d'avoir le
moindre courrier montant que l'on a
demandé qu'on a engagé une démarche rien
du tout
et après on se rend compte qu'on est
dans le mur c'est-à-dire qu'il y a pas
le budget pour finir l'action bah oui ça
c'est je veux dire c'est presque c'est
presque écrit je pense que ça aussi ça a
quand même dû voir un petit peu
je redis que le oui les constats fait
par rapport de l'Inspection générale de
l'administration sur l'uspm sont assez
sévères oui
sur le contrôle et pardon puisque vous
dites les règles existent elles n'ont
pas été mises en œuvre respectées bon là
il y a manifestement des défaillances et
des fautes mais peut-être pour les
règles de contrôle et de suivi puisque
au départ je rappelle c'était
un point d'État au bout de 6 mois pour
certaines associations ça durait bien
au-delà et ça a été même pas sûrement
compliqué est-ce que vous envisagez des
certaines évolutions c'est c'est une
question ouverte parce que on sait très
bien que si c'est pour faire passer plus
de temps à contrôler une action qu'on
met en oeuvre il faut aussi trouver le
je pense que juste équilibre dans une
relation qui normalement est une
confiance sauf peut-être ou on peut se
dire que quand on ne connaît pas les
associations qu'on prend le pari de la
nouveauté
ça peut se gérer par convention
peut-être de manière différente ce qui
me choquerait pas
comme vous le dites très justement
monsieur le rapporteur il faut trouver
le subtil équilibre le juste équilibre
entre le contrôle qui ne doit pas être
étouffant et la nécessité d'impulser en
permanence des actions
il est évident que
[Musique]
c'est un équilibre précaire et qu'il est
plus facile
de
procéder de trouver cet équilibre quand
on a en face de soi des opérateurs
associatifs connus
solide assis sur une antériorité dans le
travail avec l'administration mais ça ne
doit pas interdire de de trouver en
permanence ou de rechercher de nouveaux
partenaires sinon finalement on
s'enferme dans une forme de confort et
comme je le disais tout à l'heure
parlons d'un domaine les réseaux sociaux
ou tout bouge très vite les acteurs les
plus les plus performants les plus
percutants sont pas forcément les plus
visibles c'est un vrai défi pour
l'administration ça
vous êtes
une dernière question vous êtes en même
temps directeur adjoint du cabinet
d'administrateur c'est traditionnel
comme tient un ministre délégué est-ce
que le ministre intérieur vous a
questionné sur ce sujet c'est une
informer
à une un commentaire le ministre de
l'intérieur a été informé par la
secrétaire d'État de l'existence
d'alerte à partir de la fin du mois de
mars du début du mois d'avril il s'est
d'ailleurs je crois exprimé devant la
représentation nationale en réponse à
une question à l'Assemblée nationale
absolument de réponse à une question au
gouvernement
donc oui il est informé bien sûr et le
par ailleurs je rappelle mais vous
l'avez dit en introduction de cette de
cette séance que le pilotage de
l'activité du secrétariat général du
cpdr relève de la secrétaire d'État donc
l'effectue au quotidien
pour aller pour le droit fil de ce que
vous venez de dire et la question du
président
il nous a été dit par Monsieur Gravel en
ouverture de son audition que il y avait
une commande politique donc la commande
politique vous avez un ministre vous
avez des secrétaires d'État avec une
mission mais effectivement vous venez de
le redire sous l'autorité d'un ministre
donc
qu'est-ce que dans la chaîne des
responsabilités et de l'importance quand
même du sujet dont on va redire qu'il
est pas tout à fait mineur regarde
l'événement à l'origine et à la genèse
du fond Marianne la
l'importance de du sujet lors de la mise
en œuvre j'imagine quand même qu'il y a
des temps de validation entre le
secrétaire d'État ou la secrétaire
d'État et le ministre et qui il y a au
moins un suivi sur un sujet comme
celui-ci ce qui paraît normal au regard
de la problématique générale de la lutte
contre les terrorisme le séparatisme etc
et du combat pour faire prévaloir les
valeurs de la République et ne pas
baisser la garde donc vous pouvez
peut-être nous préciser qu'elles sont
les échanges les rapports les
validations
s'agissant monsieur le rapporteur de la
commande politique qui a présidé à la au
lancement du fond Marianne je ne peux
évidemment pas vous répondre puisque
comme vous savez je n'étais pas en
fonction ni la secrétaire d'État à ce
moment-là et qui a et pardon et vous
confierez bien que même sur ce sujet il
y a peut-être qu'un des traces à un
endroit à défaut du secrétariat d'État
au ministère ou à l'Élysée puisqu'à un
moment nous a dit qu'il y avait il y
aurait pu y avoir des décisions comme ça
a été dit par plusieurs des personnes
que vous avez auditionnées la politique
de contre discours républicain
effectivement émane une décision du
Président de la République c'est prise à
l'occasion enfin dans le contexte très
particulier de la fin de l'année 2020
donc ça émane de là évidemment
merci trois de nos collègues vont vous
poser trois questions vous pourrez
répondre brièvement si vous voulez bien
Vincent et blé
oui merci monsieur le Président Monsieur
le Directeur de Cabinet notre collègue
rapporte en général Jean-François évoqué
je me suis déjà interrogé mais je
voulais vous questionner sur un point
particulier qui est dans ce processus de
validation d'opération de
subventionnement à des montants qui ne
sont pas négligeables pour des
associations qui viennent d'être créés
alors vous avez dit tout à l'heure que
j'irai
le sujet sur lequel
il est convenu d'intervenir en l'espèce
est un sujet relativement j'irai mouvant
évolutif et que donc il faut bien en
tenir compte moi je dois vous dire que
j'ai présidé pendant 11 années une
importante collectivités française dans
le top 10 des collectivités
départementales de ce pays on distribué
en quelque sorte des subventions à des
associations par centaines même très
vraisemblablement par milliers j'ai pas
le chiffre mais pour des montants
excessivement raisonnables qui peuvent
être de l'ordre de 250 euros pour un
club de retraité une association
d'anciens combattants que sais-je et que
jamais en 11 années je n'en tire pas
gloriole puisque ce dispositif existait
avant que l'on soit élu président et
autant je sache il perdure après mon
départ donc aucune association qui ne
soit en capacité de fournir un minima
j'irai des comptes arrêtés vous avez dit
qu'on vous demandiez les comptes les
comptes arrêter sur un exercice donc en
fait on ne subventionne pas une
association sur sa première année
d'existence ça n'existe même pas jamais
voilà ça me paraît être une précaution
absolument minimum donc je ne sais pas
vous dites que vous avez respecté un
certain nombre de procédures je ne les
connais pas mais en tout cas celle-là
semble-t-il mais pas une procédure
écrite vous dites elles n'ont pas été
respectées est-ce que est-ce que cette
caractéristique particulière je dirais
existe et a été méconnu ou est-ce
qu'elle n'existe pas et qu'il
conviendrait sans doute l'introduire
dans notre arsenal à défaut que ce soit
légal à tout le mois réglementaire
je vous propose si vous êtes d'accord de
prendre les trois questions comme ça
vous répondrez Marc la Mini et Daniel
briller
oui merci monsieur le Président Monsieur
le Rapporteur Monsieur le Directeur
merci pour je dirais cet échange
sur le directeur merci pour pour cet
échange
sur j'irai
l'examen un petit peu de
ce qui était fait donné à ses
associations bénéficiaires alors j'ai
retenu le nombre de 17 associations
bénéficiaires
enfin ce qui peut nous interpeller parce
que c'est
pour les valeurs de la République on
soutient etc mais
des associations que moi je connais pas
bien localement que je connais pas du
tout vu que leurs interventions sont que
sur les réseaux sociaux alors que bon
c'est vrai dans nos départements et
territoire respectifs on a l'habitude
des bénévoles d'un côté il y a des
associations qui ont un certain nombre
de salariés mais ça peut rester modeste
même si c'est là pour des des
théoriquement des grandes causes
alors ce qui peut surprendre
c'est le reportage de la cité le comité
de sélection alors qui composent ou qui
a composé ce comité de sélection des
dossiers pour retenir ses projets puis
c'est quand même des montants je rejoins
il y a une telle rigueur pour les
subventions aux associations que ce soit
des portées par les collectivités
territoriales mais aussi par l'État bon
on a cité le FIB le FIP des mais je
prends pour les associations il y a le
fond de développement de la vie
associatif qui est sur l'autorité
l'éducation nationale jeunesse sport via
sociative où là c'est pareil il y a
quand même une rigueur sur l'instruction
des dossiers c'est des sommes bon qui
vont qui sont
à partir de 750 euros mais ça reste
j'irai modeste parce que là ce qui nous
effraie c'est quand même des sommes de
100.000 155 200.000 ou autre et que le
résultat des actions voilà merci
beaucoup merci Marc Daniel broyer puis
Thierry aussi et rapide en fait j'ai
deux questions la première vous avez
évoqué la rigueur de l'instruction des
équipes du cipdr et en fait cette
rigueur a eu deux de défaillances et
c'est sur les deux associations qui
semblent avoir été orienté vers le fond
Marianne par le cabinet c'est ce que je
comprends à ce stade du dossier donc je
m'interroge je ne vois que deux causes
soyez une défaillance administrative qui
est un peu en contradiction avec la
rigueur que vous avez évoquée du travail
du cipdr soit il y avait une volonté
politique qui faisait que
l'administration se disait il faut
malgré tout instruire même si c'est pas
exactement ma rigueur habituelle
d'instruction je voudrais comprendre
votre analyse et puis ma deuxième
question c'est est-ce qu'une stratégie
est-ce qu'on peut mettre en trois
semaines une stratégie profonde de
contre discours
sur les réseaux sociaux de
contrediscours citoyens enfin citoyens
civique associatif est-ce que c'est
envisageable pour un pour un haut cadre
de se demander quand demander en trois
semaines de mettre en place une telle
stratégie est-ce que ça ne demande pas
parce que le sujet
ambitieux et très important de prendre
un peu le temps
plus approfondie de l'analyse moi j'ai
eu l'impression qu'au fond on s'est dit
dans ce délai si court on va prendre les
premiers qu'on connaît et on va leur
demander de faire plutôt que de
construire cette stratégie que vous avez
évoquée comme étant une stratégie
merci Daniel Thierry Cosic merci
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Directeur j'avais une question qui non
pas qui sort du cadre de la de la
commission d'enquête mais pour essayer
de se projeter ma question et la
suivante j'ai pas eu la chance de
parcourir votre CV mais j'imagine que
dans des expériences en cabinet que vous
avez est-ce que je m'interroge le fait
de savoir s'il y a aujourd'hui il existe
une doctrine en matière d'attribution
des subventions de l'État aux
associations est-ce que c'est le c'est
le premier ministre qui a un moment le
secrétariat du Premier ministre qui
donne des instructions dans les
ministères sur la manière de de
d'attribuer ces subventions est-ce qu'il
existe des dossiers type est-ce que quel
est le contrôle en fait est-ce qu'à un
moment il existe de la doctrine et
est-ce que si jamais ce n'est pas le cas
est-ce que vous pensez pas qu'avec ce
genre de d'affaires tel que telle il
existe qui serait pertinent que on
y est des recommandations qui soient
faites pour pour avancer en ce sens
merci merci Thierry c'est directeur sur
le Président je vais essayer de répondre
de manière aussi synthétique que
possible le président est blé
vous m'interrogez par votre propos sur
des la présence dans les lauréats du
fond Marianne d'association
ayant été récemment créée je ne peux
malheureusement pas j'en suis désolé
commenter les les circonstances dans
lesquelles ont été attribués les
subventions en avril 21 on choisit les
lauréats je n'étais pas en fonction à
l'époque
et au-delà de ça au-delà de la question
particulière de l'appel à projet fond
Marianne il y a des règles juridiques
qui régissent l'obtroa de subvention
publique il faut les naturellement les
respecter
et ça ça me
discute pas
monsieur le sénateur la mini vous m'avez
interrogé sur là aussi des opérations
enfin sur le l'appel à projet de d'avril
2021 les conditions de sélection qui
composaient le comité de sélection là
aussi je suis regrets de ne pas pouvoir
vous répondre du reste je crois que la
question a été évoquée lors d'audition
précédente donc je suis au regret de ne
pas pouvoir répondre précisément à votre
question qui porte sur des faits bien
antérieurs à ma prise de fonction
monsieur le sénateur brûlez vous m'avez
interrogé sur là aussi alors première
partie de votre question sur les deux
grosses associations donc je vous ferai
la même réponse qu'à vos collègues pour
les mêmes raisons votre deuxième
question
peut-être porter plus générale et
consistait à savoir si on pouvait pour
reprendre vos termes construire une
stratégie de contreditours républicain
en trois semaines alors je voudrais
peut-être préciser un point qui me
semble important la stratégie de contre
discours républicain tel qu'elle a été
voulue par le président de la République
à la fin de l'année 2020 ne se résume
pas à l'appel à projets font Marianne
elle porte sur d'autres types d'actions
qui ont été je crois développés lors de
l'audition que vous avez eu ce matin
les actions qui s'inscrivent dans la
durée ça c'est très important de le
rappeler ça n'est pas un coup ponctuel
si vous me permettez l'expression la
stratégie de contredisco républicain si
on veut qu'elle produise des effets elle
doit se dérouler dans la durée et ça
c'est très important de le rappeler donc
le je crois qu'il faut voilà décorréler
les deux sujets
monsieur le sénateur Cozic pour terminer
existe-t-il une doctrine dans
l'attribution des subventions
il existe des règles juridiques
applicables et qui par construction
doivent être respectées
il existe par ailleurs des priorités
politiques des impulsions politiques
donnaient au niveau central par les
membres du gouvernement
je voudrais juste rappeler une évidence
et enfoncer une porte ouverte et je m'en
veux presque de le faire devant vous
mais l'écrasante majorité des
subventions qui sont accordées dans
notre pays le slon le son par des
acteurs locaux et c'est heureux
les subventions attribuées au niveau
central sont l'exception les subventions
attribuées au niveau local sont la règle
donc le respect des règles il vaut pour
tout le monde le respect du corpus
juridique qui encadre l'attribution de
subventions il vaut pour tout le monde à
l'échange centrale comme à l'échelle
mais je voudrais partager avec vous ce
constat c'est évident c'est que l'octroi
des subventions il obéit d'abord à des
réalités locales et je pense que c'est
une bonne chose
je vous remercie
bien c'est le directeur merci
pour cette audition
et je vous souhaite une bonne fin de
journée ainsi qu'à vous mes chers
collègues